para combatir la escasez de agua un
grupo de expertos están levantando
glaciares artificiales en los andes de
chile con tecnología desarrollada en
india todo un avance que pretende
garantizar el abastecimiento de agua en
las comunidades chilenas conocido como
proyecto ni los virus nace como una
inspiración que busca principalmente
trabajar sobre el gran problema de la
crisis que estamos viendo y diera tanto
en chile como en el mundo
disponibilidad o agua que existe hoy día
en ciertos momentos del año en la
cordillera puede resguardar la para
poder entregarla en época de festivales
el proyecto consiste en almacenar las
lluvias del invierno austral en los
glaciares artificiales para utilizarlas
en los secos meses de verano cada vez
más áridos por las sequías relacionadas
con la crisis climática mundial en
locación podamos el agua en este caso
por ejemplo en el parque arenas que
tenemos nuestro primer prototipo ya la
tomamos y la conducimos un poco más
abajo para que esta diferencia de
potencial genere energía que pago
dispersando hacia el aire y que se
congele con la diferencia temperatura en
el cajón del maipo al sureste de
santiago de chile- ella han lanzado las
estructuras artificiales y tienen como
meta recolectar 100 millones de litros
de agua que servirán para abastecer a
aproximadamente 100.000 personas durante
tres meses si le lleva años inmerso en
una gran sequía y los expertos avisan
del peligro que corren los glaciares del
país en constante retroceso